Is fasting obligatory upon all Muslims
or is there a distinct group that Allah
refers to when it comes to fasting in
the month of Ramadan particularly?
Alhamdulillah
there are five conditions to be
fulfilled to make fasting obligatory on
any person. Number one is he or she
should be a Muslim. Number two, the
person should be sane.
Number three, he or she should have
reached the age of puberty. That means
he or she should be an adult. Number
four, the person should be healthy.
Number five, the person should not be in
a state of traveling. He or she should
be settled. There are additional four
conditions for a female to be fulfilled.
If it's a woman, if it's a lady, if it's
a female, there are additional four
conditions should be fulfilled to make
it obligatory on her. Number one is that
she should not be menstruating.
She should not be in a position where
she has post-natal bleeding. She should
not be breastfeeding and she should not
be pregnant. So for a woman, if all
these nine conditions are fulfilled,
then it becomes obligatory on her. And
for the male only the first five
conditions have to be fulfilled to make
it compulsory for them to fast in the
month of Ramadan.